The equation is given to us
-2u (y ^ 2 + su-3)
is equal to dy ^ 3 + 12u ^ 2 + fy.
Pause the video and try
find the variables c, d and f.
Okay, now let's solve it together.
At first it may seem a little frightening.
We just have an equation to find
these three variables.
How will you do it?
A sensible approach would be
to simplify what we have here on the left.
To simplify it, we can simply uncover the brackets
and multiply it in this multi-member,
by (u ^ 2 + su - 3).
And then in the equality to see
whether we can tie the odds.
So let's reveal the brackets.
Let's first think how much -2 u of u ^ 2.
This is minus 2u ^ 3.
Since the y of the first y of the square is y of the third degree.
Okay, now, let's multiply-2 on su.
This is minus 2 per cent
and then there is a y y.
Consequently, minus 2% ^ 2.
And then we will multiply minus 2u on ...
not forgetting,
that we bring out 3 here,
so we can treat it as minus 3.
Minus 2 minus 3 is plus 6,
and there we have that y.
Done, we have simplified
the left side of this equation.
Now let's see if ...
Let me actually write
the right side with different colors
and then we can just think of it.
This third grade member,
member y ^ 3 is blue,
so let me write the article u ^ 3 here also with blue.
So, yes.
And then I wrote the article u ^ 2 with purple,
so let me also write the article y ^ 2 with purple.
Plus 12th of a square.
And then, finally, but not least,
I have written this first-degree member in green - this article,
so let me write the first grade member
here is also green, plus fy.
And when you look at it this way, you see
which members coincide with which other members.
We can see that
here I have a third degree member.
This must correspond to this third grade member there.
So d should be equal to minus 2.
Let's record it,
d is equal to -2.
We see the second grade member.
This second-grade member responds
of this second grade member there.
So this shows us that this factor 12
should be equal to -2c.
Let's write it down, -2c is equal to 12.
To find with we can divide the two sides into -2.
c is equal to 12 divided by -2, which is -6.
There is logic in that c is -6,
removing 2 by -6,
is subtracting -12,
which will be the same as the addition of 12.
Then we get exactly the same factor
for the second degree member.
I think you can see where things are going.
Here we have six for the first grade member.
Here we have fy in the first grade member.
This f should be the same,
must be equal to the coefficient here.
So f must be equal to 6.
And we're ready.
And the key to understanding here is that you connect
members with the appropriate degree.
I do not want to be too complicated,
but the simplest way to find it,
is like realizing: "Okay, I have a third degree member here,
I have a third degree member here as well.
If I look at it simply enough, the way
I will get this third grade member here,
is by using this third grade member. "
And I just look at the odds and say,
"Okay, they have to have the same odds."
And then I say "d is equal to minus 2",
and then proceed in the same way.